oui on a décidé de faire un quiz il ya
des informations issues de votre livre
au tour de france des curiosités
naturelles et scientifiques nous allons
avoir en face à face
le père dans des épreuves de koh lanta
benjamin castaldi
face à notre put science notre docteur
agrégé et agréé doc gynéco
c'est votre dernière chance puisque le
perdant de ce quiz sera envoyé dans
l'espace
à auxerre tout comme vous je peux être à
doc gynéco dans l'espace ça va pas
beaucoup de changer
[Rires]
c'est pas non plus un changement de ouf
jobs a alors attention alors toutes les
infos je vous dis elles sortent du livre
de jamie mon tour de france des
curiosités naturelles et scientifique
première question c'est pour doc way qui
étaient les passagers du vol en ballon
organisé le 19 septembre 1783 par les
frères montgolfier un coq un canard et
un mouton un loup un renard et une
boulette ou une souris un lapin une
tortue ben c est donc une fois
l'appareil tant que chien op c'est jamie
qui répond jamais eh bien c'est la
réponse à un coach et un canard et un
bouton et where he est alors pourquoi un
mouton parce que là on a deux volatiles
on a un mouton ça c'est intéressant
qu'on a déjà vu qu'on avait deux
volatiles mans et oui et c'est là qu'on
en voit on en voit des êtres vivants
dans les airs alors alain cocq et un
canard on dit oui ils peuvent supporter
les airs mais un mouton c'est un
mammifère est donc envoyé un ami faire
dans les airs on ne savait pas du tout
ce que ça allait donner
et c'était un petit peu une manière de
franchir un verrou de se dire si on peut
envoyer un mouton on pourra envoyer un
bon c'est ouf
mais c'est vrai eu comme un déclic je
les colle écoute et d élever ses paroles
sur ma mission alors vous avez donc vous
avez une mauvaise réponse que donc c'est
un coq un canard et un mouton ce vol a
été réalisé à versailles et sous les
yeux de louis saez absolument succès il
a vu comme ça rien n'est encore toute sa
tête
[Rires]
nous la question pour vous qu'est ce tu
as dit oui pourquoi cette certaines
races de vaches ont des taches noires
autour des yeux un pour avoir du style
comme doc gynéco du style c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de styles regarder les
beaux gosses pour que les mouches ne
voient pas leurs cieux ou pour se
protéger du soleil
forcément là c'est pour se protéger du
soleil alors est ce que c'est ça exact
la bonne réponse les vaches alors raison
elles ont gambadé des taches noires pour
se protéger du soleil
alors ça absorbe les particuliers en
particulier les vaches qui vont grimper
dans les alpages
celle ci c'est marrant ça doit être une
pie noir ou une normande alors ça sera
l'association
ça suffit la mise à l'épreuve mais elle
est trop mignonne l armée mais concède
pour 7 pour certaines vaches c'est très
très utile celle dont je parle dans le
livre qui est la tarentaise houle
attarine c'est une vache qui va monter
dans les alpages et où au moment où elle
monte dans les alpages j'ai encore des
névés sur les pentes et donc elle va
elle doit se protéger de la
réverbération du soleil et donc cesser
ce tour quelle auto on a l'impression
qu'elle est maquillée très montage être
mais ça reste protégé donc elle va se
protéger et crash si moi j'y passais se
parler des heures avec des vagues chez
moody ouais tu dois et qu'elles seront
ou non oui comment elles font les vaches
unis par amp les salers comme ils font
bon ménage
[Rires]
comment ils font alors non mais c'est
une très bonne question
la salers elle a une robe bring dans
l'année donc d'emblée elle est protégée
en revanche une vache qui avait qui va
avoir une robe blanche s'est fait
attendre charolais allez vous promener
dans damgan dans la campagne ou à la
montagne si vous voyez une vache qui n'a
pas le tour des yeux noirs bien vous
allez remarquer qu'elle pleure c'est
vrai c'est vrai vous avez raison et moi
un moment j'avais vu des vaches hommage
aux reliques
c'est comme ça et c'est comme ça que
vous êtes allé les voir ils vont bien
sûr america line et ma mère et moi j'ai
pas des vases antiques arrivé tout et
j'adore on apprend des choses sérieuses
je kiffe doux c'est génial
attention donc à vous mais sous quel nom
est plus connu la bêta vulgaris la
batavia kelly vdev dit dans la betterave
et l'âge et av
c'est la betterave témoin la betterave
la betterave bonnes réponses pourquoi la
big apple app établi arrive plus assez
dans le livre de jamie 1
alors il s'appelle la bêta vulgaris
parce que en fait les botanistes quand
ils doivent donner un nom à une plante
et bien il s'inspire de ce qu'ils ont
autour d'eux et quand on regarde la rn27
betteraves et bien elle ressemble à la
lettre bêta a le b de brigades de grecs
voilà si j'avais été un alpha comment
ils se la pètent serait qu'un cador qui
connaît le fameux grec ici à ouaga alfa
beta gamma delta epsilon l'état est à tu
et à utah qu'en cas pas lambda minuk si
omicron pire au sigma tau philippe 6
oméga
vous connaissez aucun n'a vraiment
franchement station il ya personne est
aussi se le dire à serge jamais stokab
atteint à la jambe et alphabet grecque
voilà à quoi vous étiez vous étiez ou
alors c'est un charmant pompiers qui est
venu pour pour mettre un petit peu de
glace sur un essai proposé très
gentiment je remercie il passera à la
maison pour voir si ça si ça pas en fait
le bras n'a pas enflé allez vous tirer
et il est tout à coup j'ai pas coiffée
lâcher vraiment pur alors moi je vous
dit vous êtes magnifique le pompier là
le pompier de talbot aux avocats le
train à tokyo bon ça m'agace elle il ya
un poids partout mais vous avez une
question - quel événement à populariser
la pomme de terre pour la première fois
à la pomme de terre moi je suis un fou
de pommes de terre la patate alors louis
saez apporter un rameau de fleurs de
pommes de terre à la boutonnière des
charrettes les ont distribués
gratuitement aux habitants où cyril
lignac a revisité l'écraser de pommes de
terre
non je pense je pense que je pense que
c'est je pense que c'est là à la donc
poussé zaporijia rameaux de fleurs alors
c'est juste et absolument il a porté la
veille de son anniversaire et plein de
monde à versailles il a accepté de
porter des fleurs de pommes de terre à
la boutonnière et marie antoinette a
accepté d'avoir une couronne de fleurs
de pommes de terre dans les choux et
dans le livre que j'ai lu vous dites
justement et moi ça marche parce que
franchement ça m'a pris un bruit j'étais
persuadé que le roi de la pomme de terre
c'était vicoigne sébacées louis seize
sélectionnés parce qu'il le dit il dit
le roi de la pop se taire c'est lucette
groupe à vous le dis dans le livre je le
dis les mecs effectivement cet inventeur
il y en a qui bossent 1
vu matchs dans la lah attention je peux
vous le dire
question juste pour vous vous avez perdu
mais comme ça alors quelle année a été
recensé le premier fabricant de savons
de marseille
il n'y a pas de réduire pas de réponses
possibles 1889
merci c'était 1370 vous irez dans
l'espace à l'instar de gilles et conrad
dans l'espace